I know what you're thinking but they're
here to help off colors meet the
diamonds hi everyone and welcome back to
the things we've got some mind-blowing
Steven universe series lined up for you
and they make so much sense also we're
pretty sure we figured out who the
mystery villain is going to be in the
new Steven universe movie and it's not
who you might think it is watch until
the end to find out what's in the chest
in lion's mane this burning question has
been on the minds of fans since it was
first introduced in the first season of
Steven universe Steven tried to use
Rose's key on the chest but it was way
too big to fit into the lock on the
treasure chest many fans have written
theories as to what could be in this
chest one of the most popular theories
is that the chest holds pink diamonds
gem or the shattered pieces of the gem
this has since been debunked of course
we all know that steven has that
gemstone so what could possibly be in
the chest some people think it's a
message from Rose to Steven there could
be some important information that she
wants only Steven to hear maybe it's the
key to peace between the crystal gems
and the Diamonds one fan suggested that
the design on the front of the chest
resembles a sword we can kind of see his
point and that would go well with his
pink shield although Steven is more of a
lover than a fighter maybe it contains
ancient secrets about the beginning of
the diamonds and how to defeat them and
prevent them from destroying any more
worlds what do you guys think leave your
theory in the comment section below
where do pearls come from early is one
of the original crystal gems she fought
alongside pink diamond in the rebellion
on earth she was originally made for a
pink diamond as an offering from the
other diamonds to make her happy
pearl was loyal to pink diamond and
traveled with her to many other planets
you're welcome my diamond [ __ ] pearl
you're gonna get us in trouble
during the gem war girl was roses friend
and confidant Rose told her many but not
all secrets pearl has been a valuable
friend to Steven and the other crystal
gems but where exactly do pearls come
from this question has plagued the crew
naver's for many seasons the ends up
wondered if homeworld has giant oyster
farm somewhere that makes
one fan speculated that they come from
giant space oysters or spoi stirs the
fact that Pearl is made from organic
material makes sense after all she does
have sand manipulation abilities lapis
peridot fusion the crew naver's has
speculated for a long time about what a
lapis peridot fusion would be like this
fan art posted by redditor crunchyroll
is pretty popular among fans people have
wondered if their fusion would become
permanent like that of ruby and sapphire
when they come together to create garnet
the fans have expressed that they would
still want to see lapis and peridot as
separate characters instead of a
permanent lapid a fusion character
there's a lot of curiosity about what
kind of powers they would have its use
one pretty amazing theory is that they
might create a liquid metal that can be
hardened to forge weapons when you think
about it it makes a lot of sense how do
you combine liquid control with metal
control liquid metal of course one fan
pointed out that both lapis and peridot
abilities could combine to work together
since peridot favors projectile
abilities and lapis uses water to create
weapons a combination of lapis is more
freeform style with peridot strategic
aggressive style would be really cool to
see fans thought mercury would be a
likely name for the fused character but
an even better name suggestion was
Quicksilver maybe we'll get to see this
in the upcoming Steven universe movie
yellow diamond helmet debate there has
been a huge debate in the croon averse
about whether yellow diamond is wearing
a helmet or if that's just her hair
several fans think she has an upturned
hairdo that fits in nicely with her
1980s businesswoman image but others
think it's a yellow helmet this has led
fans to speculate as to what is under
her helmet besides her bottled up
feelings of course one fan wonders if
she's completely bald underneath like
the king in Spongebob Squarepants the
movie superfan austra fox loves yellow
diamond
he describes her as a complex character
who has been known to be cold and
uncaring we know that yellow diamond
really misses pink diamond but awestruck
Fox believes that she stuffs all of her
her feelings away inside that yellow
helmut so what else is tucked away
inside yellow diamonds helmet besides
her feelings is it flowing yellow hair a
shiny yellow bald spot or is it hair
that holds the exact same style and
shape of her helmet we may never know
the answer the Cinderella reference fans
have been quick to point out the
similarities between Steven universe in
the classic Disney movie Cinderella
white diamond has been compared to the
wicked stepmother who is dismissive
always lurking and cruel that would make
yellow diamond than blue diamond the
evil stepsisters there's still wicked
like their mother but also victims of
her abuse White has a lot of strict
rules that they must follow in order to
escape her wrath the pebbles bear a
close resemblance to the mice in
Cinderella's story fans were pretty
accurate when they predicted that
Cinderella or Steven would have to get
the sisters or yellow and blue on his
side they both learned the error of
their ways and feel remorse for their
behavior then they come up against white
diamond who is the true obstacle to
peace white diamond must learn to accept
others including herself flaws and all
if I'm not perfect and Who am I these
similarities are undeniable so will
there be more references to the classic
movie in s use future we'll have to wait
and see obsidian fans we're losing their
minds when they witness the first fusion
of the five og crystal gem characters in
the episode titled change your mind
Ruby and Sapphire as Garnett used with
amethyst pearl and Steven to form this
massive powerful being with eight arms
flaming orange eyes dark grey skin and
black curly hair with molten red
markings
[Music]
she was an incredible sight to behold
according to the Steven universe wiki of
age there's a very cool reference where
Steven's clothes can be seen on one of
the obsidians hands this is referring to
the iconic shot of Steven's laundry
hanging in the crystal temple
obsidian has a lower mouthful of hot
lava she puts all the weapons from the
crystal gems together to make a sword
handle and then forges the blade from
the lava inside her bottom mouth fans
are wishing they could read gem language
because something was inscribed on the
lava sword but no one knows for sure
what it says tumblr user Pacific Moon
cookies found a correlation between gem
language and the Korean language this
fan translated it for the crew naver's
directly translated it means the
everyone if you follow a deeper
translation it becomes all of us which
makes sense seeing as how they all
needed to fuse together to form this
powerful being
nice work Pacific moon cookies that is
seriously impressive self-acceptance the
final episode of season 5 was as
emotionally impactful as it was exciting
white diamond showed us the answer to
the question what will happen if
Steven's gem is removed much to White's
dismay pink diamond doesn't appear it's
just Steven he dances with himself to
refuse after his gem is removed den of
geek writer Seamus Kelly believes this
to be a metaphor for self love and
self-acceptance many fans have made
correlations between White's dominance
and family abuse it's been called a
giant metaphor for dysfunctional family
dynamics white is the parent trying to
force her children to be perfect she
tries to drain out their imperfections
which make them beautiful and unique as
Steven points out this is because she
can't fully accept herself and her own
flaws if you just let everyone be
whoever they are maybe you could let
yourself be whoever you are too so what
is the antidote to this fans believe
it's Steven's display of self love and
self-acceptance he also relies on
support from Connie who literally
carries his lifeless body back to his
gem so this proves that we all need
support in order to heal this made
everyone cry and it wasn't because of
Blue's powers the meaning of the colors
if you're an artist you may already be
from the
with the CMYK color model CMYK refers to
the four colors in this model which are
cyan magenta yellow and key or black
many fans couldn't help but notice that
the colors on the CMYK color model look
very similar to the diamond authority
logo another fan pointed out that the
acronym for the latest episode change
your mind is cym in this epic season
finale
yellow diamond blue diamond and pink
gemston come together to stop white
diamond
the color model shows how colors can
change when you fuse them together this
is a very obvious symbol of unity it
perfectly ties in with the fan theory
that all of us was inscribed on obsidian
slava sword in Gem language so maybe all
of us included more than the original
crystal gems who came together to form
obsidian maybe all of us means everyone
including yellow blue and white diamond
that would explain why they're all on
the beach together at the end of the
episode
who knew color models could be so
meaningful is season 6 happenings fans
are eagerly anticipating Steven universe
a movie which is coming in the fall of
2019 but what about the fate of the show
fans who watched the final episode of
season 5 change your mind but it seems
like a series finale not just a season
finale so what's next for the future of
Steven universe show creator Rebecca
sugar and former executive producer Ian
Jones 40 discussed this on a recent SU
podcast Ian said that change your mind
isn't the end of the Steven universe
franchise but that it's the end to this
particular story arc for the characters
Rebecca sugar added that moving forward
everything will be different and did
confirm that this version of the story
is done it's unclear if they're planning
on going forward with just a movie or if
there's more in store for these
characters all we know so far about the
movie is that there is a spinning heart
gem and a new villain but who is the new
villain the mystery villain the Internet
is buzzing with ideas about the
mysterious villain whose silhouette
appears in the heart gemstone on the
Steven universe movie teaser in the
teaser we catch a glimpse of a sinister
shadow and a nefarious laugh but that's
pretty much all we have to go on so who
could this shadowed villain be one
theory
that it's a new character resulting from
a fusion we just witnessed the biggest
fusion yet with obsidian this opens the
doors to the possibility of other large
group fusions so this villain could
actually be several gems fused together
another theory is that it's some sort of
corrupted gem it's certainly possible
we've seen what can happen to gems when
they're corrupted another theory is that
an alien from a different world will
create some chaos and challenge the
diamonds maybe they'll introduce
something even more powerful though
we're not sure what could be stronger
than a diamond one reddit fan thinks it
will be Sadie this fan pointed out that
the preview of the comic reveals that
harmony core or heart gem can have
effects on organics and gems who touch
it apparently the comic also emphasized
Sadie's importance this fan believes
that the mysterious face in the teaser
has the same face shape as Sadie fans
are hoping for a battle with Lars and
Sadie everyone agrees that would be epic
so who do you think the mystery villain
will be in Steven universe the movie if
you agree that it could be Sadie leave a
sparkling pink heart emoji in the
comments and that's a wrap
thanks for watching our Steven universe
series if you love this show as much as
we do subscribe to the things and give
this video a big thumbs up we'll see you
next time
[Music]